we begin here at five with victoria saha
she is on scene right near charleston in
fremont
this is all that's left of the four
alarm fire from almost two weeks ago
charred pieces of the building still
barely hanging on today new video shows
police officers trying to evacuate
everyone you gotta go sir this place is
on fire let's go metro police doing
everything they can to make sure
residents get out as flames intensify
in the early morning hours of june 19 a
massive fire in this area of downtown
las vegas destroyed dozens of buildings
and two dozen cars with 150 fire
personnel on scene trying to control the
blaze other first responders are seen
going door to door making sure no one
was stuck inside even trying to break
down the doors nearly 100 people were
evacuated
after the fire was controlled an
investigation started to see what could
have caused this four alarm fire
las vegas fire and rescue officials say
this was the largest fire they have seen
in 25 years an arson dog was out here to
figure out what could have caused this
but it did not pick up on anything
victoria saha live local now